I have a GPS ID and ID key I will provide you with their details like their API URL etc.
Bhavya, can you tell us a little bit about AuthConfig?
AuthConfig is basically an API of some vendors for which we need to call their tokens.
If we want to call their API.
So what is AuthConfig basically?
Suppose we have a login API from which we call their tokens.
Then we use that token to call their next API.
So AuthConfig is basically the same as if we want to call their API from the token itself.
And if we want to set up an API then what do we have to do in AuthConfig?
I will tell you about that.
If we have only one client then we will change the ID of that client.
For that we will set up AuthConfig.
For the other two, we are taking that as our priority.
Because we have only one client in which we have AuthConfig.
The other two don't have AuthConfig.
AuthConfig is something like this.
Some APIs are open to us.
And some APIs are the ones that we have to login first.
So we have the API from the vendor's side.
As soon as we run that API, we have tracked it.
The other thing is that we have run that API to the URL.
So we have to log in there.
That means some token will be added.
Token means login.
We will be able to test everything on that behalf.
So that is AuthConfig.
We have only one client in which we have AuthConfig.
We will discuss that later.
Before that, I will tell you about the other one.
Okay?
Okay, sir.
So before track confirmation, we have the API URL.
I have made some documents for all the clients.
So if we are looking at Springdale,
the API URL starts from here.
From HTTP.
This is a question mark.
These are our query patterns.
So all the parts before this are the API URL.
The starting part.
Okay?
So we will copy this and put it here.
In the API URL.
After this, we have methods.
There are three types of methods.
Get, Post, and Post.
If we send query patterns in the API.
If we attach something after the question mark.
We call this query pattern.
And if we send it in an object.
Like this.
We send it in an object.
We call this type of post request.
Okay.
Did you understand that much?
Yes.
Okay.
So for Springdale, we will call the get method.
I have written the method to get and post.
Okay.
So we will call the get method.
And then we have the query parameters.
We attach the token in this.
Or the extra values that we have to pass to call this.
We add those in this.
In this case, we have the token.
So we get the token.
And the value is also written in front of this.
Is equal to what?
This is the whole stream.
We have to copy and paste it here.
So we have to paste this after equal to?
Yes.
Token is equal to this.
From here to the end.
So every time we have to call the get method.
What are you doing?
Every time when we will hit the API,
we will have to call the get method.
Basically, what we are setting up,
we call the API on the backend.
We have to set up this setup once.
When we use this in our app,
we will call their other API,
which is our own API.
When we call that,
our backend automatically calls on the base of the config
on the base of the API.
Then we have headers.
Headers are basically what our response will be.
What format should it be in.
We can also fill this from here.
So here we will input accept.
And its value will be application slash json.
So that the response will be in json format.
Okay.
Now we have a bus.
One second.
Let me see the ID.
Is their API running?
Hello?
Yes.
Is their springdance API running?
It is running.
I can't hit their API.
You can directly check the API.
Postman?
No, it didn't work.
It might be an issue.
No, it's running.
Live location is unavailable.
It might be an issue.
Okay.
Entity change.
Tinku, you understood the API.
Yes, sir.
I understood even the headers.
Okay.
So in track config, we just have to put the API URL.
We have to set its method.
Which we have given.
And Tinku.
Okay.
So in track config, we just have to put the API URL.
We have to set its method.
And we have to put the API URL.
In request body?
In request body.
So, like, get request or post request, what are the use cases, like, what is the situation
we have to use, what is the situation we have to post-release?
Situation wise, I mean, it depends on how they have configured the vendors in the API.
Okay, so, like, we just need to, like, put it over here.
And response config, basically, like, suppose, if we use our app or portal,
how should we get the response in return?
Okay, how do we configure this? I will run an API.
Is there an issue, sir?
Hello.
I mean, this configuration will look like this, but there won't be a track, right?
Yes, I mean, the test connection one won't be checked, right?
Because based on the response of the test connection, we will configure the response, right?
Okay, no problem, just set it up once.
The entities, the data of the entities, will be sent to me by the word file.
I have made a JSON for that.
Yes, so, you will put it in the word and send it to me in the word file.
Okay, I will give it to you.
I mean, don't make a simple copy, or send a text file or something else.
Send a text file or a word file.
Okay, by writing the name of the entity.
Okay, I can put it in the group once.
Let's complete the setup once, then let's see how to do the test.
Okay, okay. If I show it now, as I had shared it.
Let me show you one thing.
Pinku, you have to be clear. First, confirm that you have to do the setup.
The response config has not been done yet.
The other VBS config that we had, the track config has been cleared.
Okay, then you have to tell me the device ID as well.
How to set up the device ID.
Have you put the device ID now?
What is the device ID?
Okay, the wickle ID.
Yes.
No, I will tell you that. I couldn't check it there.
I have to see that.
And the issue that is coming from the check case side, is it from Ms. Resh's side or from Ms. Resh's side?
I will have to see.
Put it on the front-end.
What should I do with the setup?
There is an issue from the front-end.
I mean, the cold service is coming.
Okay, so will you put this in there as well?
Put it in the same task once.
Put it in the main task or in case?
Put it in the main task.
Okay.
Once, when will the setup come?
Normally, the response postman is coming.
Is the screen visible?
You understood so much, right?
You put the URL on A, we have to check the method,
we will add the query patterns,
the tokens, etc.
And in headers, we will add the accept application recently.
Okay.
And if our method is posted in any of them,
we will add the body in it.
In the object, the key value is there.
Okay.
Next, we have two keys left.
One is the GPS ID location
and the other is the GPS ID key.
Okay.
Now, I have mentioned in the document
that the matching key
is equal to the vehicle number.
So, we have to copy the key
mentioned here
and add it here.
In the GPS ID key.
Okay. Once again,
put it on the back.
Okay.
Just in matching key,
we will pass our ID
Basically, we will pass our ID
in this key and
the back end will match with this key.
And we will send it in the query parameter.
Okay.
So, we have
set up this much
in the track config.
Then, we have the response config.
Basically,
the response of our vendor,
vendor API, we set it up
What will be the path of the list?
Suppose, we talk about this.
So, here you can see
that we have a list in the data.
Yes.
That is why we have written
data.list here.
That is how we access
the arrays from the dot operator.
Okay.
So, data.list is our path key.
Basically, it tells us that
the data of our vendor API
will come in this.
It will come in the list array.
Okay.
Then, we have the match key.
The key
that comes in this,
the unique key,
that every vehicle has its own key.
Okay.
So, the key that we will pass
and the response that will come,
if we have to make a comparison,
with which key will we match the values?
So, here the name of that key is vehicle number.
So, we will take this
and replace it in the match key.
Okay.
Then, we have the latitude,
longitude and speed key.
This is basically the key
that we have here, latitude, longitude and speed.
We will copy these keys
and insert them there.
Just add these keys here.
Okay.
So, this is our setup.
Any issues
It's clear.
Just tell me about the match key.
The previous track config
that we did in GPS ID,
shouldn't it be the same?
Yes, it should be the same.
No, it shouldn't be the same.
The document that I will give you,
it has the matching key in it.
Okay.
So, like...
Yes?
It can be different.
The matching key
that we have to put on the track config
and the response that we will get
in the match key,
we will get the response.
Then,
till now,
we have to put the GPS ID of each vehicle.
Where is that?
We have vehicles in transport.
Okay.
Here, suppose,
if we want to configure this vehicle,
then we
search for it in our response.
there must be a vehicle.
So, the keys
that we added,
the matching key and the key key,
we have to set up
that vehicle number.
We save that
and then it will run our API.
Because it will get the data
from the vendor's API.
I will just repeat
the last one.
What we have set up till now,
if we want to run that set up,
then the vehicle key
that we have set up,
that it should be the vehicle number.
Yes.
Now, it happens that every vendor's
API,
it gives a unique core
that will be unique
for that vehicle.
If we talk about this vehicle,
then its code is
V2954.
Whenever we call on our API,
then we will call on this
value.
Because then it will match
that our back-end will also check
with this response.
Our main comparison will be on this key.
Okay.
So, what we have to do is
take its value.
When we come to this page,
V2954.
We will search the vehicle here.
By viewing this,
we will get GPS ID.
We will have to save that value here.
Okay. If we don't save it,
it will not run on our API,
it will give an error that GPS ID
is configured in it.
We will save this.
Now, if we come to our app,
here we have the trackwall bus
option.
Suppose we go to
V2954.
When we click on this,
then our vehicle's API goes
one second.
Our API
goes to this.
In this, we are sending GPS ID.
The one we set up there,
in our vehicle.
We will pass it here.
So, what we do on the back-end?
The track we have configured,
it will run it
with this GPS ID key.
And then the response
will be of this vehicle only.
And then the latitude and longitude
will be rendered here.
Okay.
So, this much setup is there.
Now, suppose here,
5861, we don't have GPS ID.
We haven't set it up.
So, here we get an error that
GPS ID is not found. Please contact us.
Okay.
Now, tell us once,
if there are any doubts in this
whole setup.
Yes, you just told us that
in these documents, we will get
matching, the response
we will get. Where will we get the response?
We will provide that also.
No, right now,
in this portal,
the response will not come.
There is an error there.
So, first, you will update the postman.
Yes.
So, in this case, normally
you can hit the postman.
Okay.
Like, just in case,
I am asking, by hitting the postman,
I can find out what data
I have to put. But the thing is,
once you can tell us where the show is
on the front end. So that, whenever
it gets updated, we can do it from there.
Okay, where will the response come on the front end?
That is the problem. Yes.
Here is the track config.
Here is the test connection.
Okay, okay.
If you click on this, it will run on A.
Right now, we have the address here.
Yes. But the response
will come here.
The postman should also come here.
Okay.
Yes.
That was it.
Aishu?
Yes, sir.
Yes, I showed the pipe one.
But the response is not coming here.
Okay.
I'll send them the data in a minute.
I told you, I'll send it here.
Because it's easy to read.
Yes, yes, send it here.
Tinku, tell us how easy it is for you.
Sir, it's the same as well.
I wanted to ask you something.
Like what you just said that we have to set up
for 2-2 buses,
should we do only 2 buses?
Or after 2, in the next entity,
should we do another 2-2?
We have to do 2 buses for every entity.
For every entity, okay sir.